as western sanctions take a toll on
russia's economy it's looking elsewhere
for markets and finding a welcome
partner in china with trade between the
two countries surging russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov says he sees
inexhaustible potential in their
relationship
can new commercial ties with china
compensate for the ones severed by the
west
could and would beijing seek to
influence russia's war on ukraine does
china hold the cards that's our question
today
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point here
are our guests felix lee writes about
the global economy for the berlin-based
daily newspaper the tots and previously
served as the paper's china
correspondent
matthew karnichinig is politico's chief
europe correspondent and based here in
berlin
and natalya's miolensiva is a colleague
working with dw news and also with dw's
russia desk and she formerly worked in
our moscow bureau
[Music]
felix
some
people both in china and russia have
been using some pretty flowery rhetoric
to describe
these new ties in fact a chinese foreign
ministry spokesman recently called it a
model for the world what does he mean by
that exactly and how would you assess
the significance of this bond well of
course china wants to take advantage of
the conflict and tries to
like
show
the new friendship and officially
outwardly
of course china is not uh is not
following the western sanctions uh china
blames the nato for uh for the war
for the escalation but interesting when
you look deep
there are no more
more
more ties uh also economically speaking
of course china
imports a little bit more gas because
gas from russia now is cheap
but if you look at the financial sector
or the technology uh where russia hopes
to get the more technology from china
there's not much happening
i see that a lot of
chinese tech firms actually are leaving
russia because for them of course the
western market is more important than
the russian and they are afraid that
that mike the u.s and the western
countries would
sanctionize also chinese companies if
they have too close ties to russia and i
want to come back to that a little bit
later matthew china and russia announced
this new
friendship as the winter olympics were
getting underway in beijing and they
talked about it there as a no limits
partnership do you take that at face
value or do you expect that china would
under certain circumstances seek to
influence russia's actions in ukraine
well it's worth remembering that both of
these countries are are very skilled in
the art of propaganda and have a very
long
history of using it to their advantage
and i think that china wouldn't hesitate
to
try and influence uh russia if it if it
saw fit and i think at this meeting it
was clear that putin sought a green
light from chi or
told him what he had in mind for
ukraine and that the chinese leadership
agreed to it thinking as putin did that
it would be a very uh quick operation
and that after a few days they would all
be celebrating
victory that of course hasn't come to
pass
natalia not long ago china and russia
actually conducted joint military
exercises how concerned should the west
be about these ties
well i think these military exercises as
as well as what we're hearing from
lavrov other signs
actually to the western audiences to the
outside world that russia is now
switching to the east which is to china
we don't need your you know western
trade we are well off without it we have
chinese partners but if we look in how
this message comes down to a domestic
audience this is totally different story
i think people in russia are not
considering themselves
you know very very close ties with china
there's never been this idea that russia
is in eastern countries in power there's
either russia is with the west or his
base by its own so i don't think it
comes down really good in the domestic
audience that we know china is our main
friend and partner i think people are
very much afraid of the chinese
influence there and what it can bring
that the assets that's going to be cheap
in russia now being bought by the
chinese companies or something like that
and then if china will rely um 100 on on
if russia will rely 100 on china that
will be new dependence for it
felix what do we know about how the
chinese people see
this this relationship do they welcome
the new friendship with russia not
really there traditionally there was
never
big trust between these two countries in
soviet times russia although they're
supposed to be
sisters countries
but
moscow looked down on beijing and
mao zedong couldn't bear it and that's
why they broke there was a big broke in
their relationship and this mistrust
distrust is still happening so i mean
china is wanting trying to take
advantage of the conflict
but there is no real close ties and no
trust
actually china had had a big project in
central asia with the new silk road and
interesting it wasn't going so much
through russia they
were focusing on the other countries
kazakhstan and ukraine
and
this plan is not working anymore with
this war happening so
actually if you look close china is not
too happy that
this war is lasting for already so long
and who knows
until it ends
trade between china and russia had in
fact been on the rise even prior to the
announcement at the winter olympics
but the fact is this is no partnership
of equals
china is by far russia's most important
trading partner
moscow sends out a fifth of its export
volume to china
but it is not among china's top 10
trading partners
this doesn't seem to bother russia's
foreign minister
eurasia is becoming the most promising
region in the world
we must take advantage of this
development
and we should not rely on the us dollar
or swift but develop our own payment
systems
however europe and the us are the main
buyers of chinese goods
so beijing is trying not to alienate
such important trading partners by
showing too much support for putin's war
against ukraine
were europe or the us to impose economic
sanctions on china the top world
exporter would lose billions
and when money is at stake
beijing's friendship with putin
evidently has limits
is the russian chinese alliance just for
show
let me pass that question straight on to
matthew and uh you know it it's clear
what russia is hoping to get from this
relationship but what's in it for china
well one thing that's in it is is cheap
energy and this is really something that
uh is worth remembering that uh china
needs energy from outside of china in
order to feed its economy it has an
insatiable appetite for oil and gas
which russia has in in large quantities
and i think this is something that
china will want from russia for for many
decades to come i don't think they want
to make themselves dependent on russia
in the same way some countries in europe
have done not to name any names but
this is certainly
a role that russia will continue to play
for china and also for the west but
that's all that russia has to offer and
this is russia's real weakness is that
it's become effectively a gas station
for
asia and
for especially europe
natalia china is an energy
country there is no doubt about that but
the fact
isn't it a fact that there are limits to
the degree which chinese energy imports
can actually compensate for the cutoff
of uh western
uh imports
yeah that's true and here are several
points first of all because of the war
the prices have gone up and this is also
not very good for china or any other
country that wants to buy a lot of
energy for russia
europe was a big market so i don't think
china or china and india or any other
countries together will can compensate
for amount of energy uh well now we're
talking about the oil that we already
have a ban on it but i think the gas is
still discussing may be coming in next
month or a year
it won't compensate 100 percent for the
losses in this regard
also the cost of transporting um
oil to or gas for that matter to other
countries are higher because um
oil tanker can reach european union in
like four days five days whether to go
to china or india will be 40 days so
it's like 10 times as as long journey 10
times as much ships and the costs will
rise and i think these countries um
will see this as an opportunity and
we'll ask russia for discounts for
gas so in that sense i don't think
russia will actually gain something it
will gain new markets but i don't think
it will gain economically from that and
let me ask you about
russian tech imports because those have
actually been precisely because the
russian industrial economy is
underdeveloped russian russians have
been importing a lot of high-tech
products from the west can china make up
for that
well i think russia is actually looking
to china and other asian countries like
south korea to fill this gap because um
technology a lot of technology in russia
is from the west and if this is a
serious issue it's issue for many
industries like from uh for the
aircrafts for instance and for many
plans so i think there is big hopes um
looking at china but um as we've already
talked about some companies some tech
companies are also leaving russia not
announcing this big but for instance
huawei is closing the shops and some
other companies chinese companies are
not delivering their tech products to
russia maybe they don't do this as
western countries really shutting the
door and saying we're going away like
mcdonald's did but
they're also
seeing this as the
risk market for them so i think business
interests might reveal here let's talk
about that uh felix because verbally at
least china has rejected the western
sanctions but it seems that chinese
companies are nonetheless complying with
them and even as you mentioned as
natalia mentioned uh being proactive
about that
so what's going on and
what's behind that the simple reason is
the western markets is much much more
important for china than for russia
europe and the u.s are the two biggest
markets for chinese and so they don't
want to
risk that so that's a simple and pretty
much the reason why uh and russia is
is a small market
it's sort of a satisfaction for the
chinese government of course that
the former rival
is now getting more and more dependent
but um
chinese don't want to risk their markets
so the western market so that's a simple
reason
matthew as the war began predictions
were rife that it would spur a new
division of the world into cold era sty
cold war-era style trading blocks do you
think that is what's happening here and
how far does that division actually go
i don't think it is happening i think
what's happening is that russia has
become very isolated and it's going to
depend increasingly on china on india as
well these are countries that haven't
sanctioned
russia there's no appetite though as
we've just heard from mr lee that
for for for china to
put its relations with other parts of
the world at risk or for chinese
companies in
in order to continue to supply the
russian market because it's just it's
not big enough it's not interesting
enough for them so i think this is going
to be a major challenge for russia going
forward uh to find countries that are
really willing to to to to trade with it
no holds barred as as was the case
before and let me just ask you about
something that was mentioned in the film
namely the idea that uh this china
russian axis represents a dollar-free
zone as it as it would as it were and
could actually spur the decline of the
dollar as a the world's reserve currency
do you think we're seeing that uh
happening
uh the short answer is no we're not
seeing it happen uh again the russian
economy is just much too small to really
force that kind of change even together
with the chinese uh there's too much
capital around the world invested in
dollars um
and i i don't see any any movement in
other countries to really want to move
away from the dollar whether in the
middle east or in latin america
certainly not in north america so um you
know i think uh this is definitely
wishful thinking on the part of the
russians
felix can you tell us how you
see beijing's tradeoffs or the way that
it would balance economic as opposed to
strategic considerations i'm thinking
for example
what it means to china that ukraine
which as you mentioned had been a good
trading partner for china is now
having its economy completely destroyed
is this something that you think china
views with equanimity
china's a little bit of course not only
a little bit worried because i mean
wheat production
ukraine
china is very dependent on
wheat imports uh from all over the world
but and ukraine was one of the biggest
provider so this is a big problem prices
in china also our right is rising and
this is a risk what the chinese
government may be at the beginning of
the war hasn't thought through but is
now becoming much
more and more a problem because nothing
the communist leader they fear nothing
else than social instability and when
prices are rising also in china
that might
be a threat also to to their leadership
so
it hasn't been all thought through
um
but more and more china is getting where
it is the longer the this war lasts
let's in fact take a look at those
global implications of russia's war
against ukraine it has sent fuel and
food prices soaring a hunger crisis is
looming and the world bank recently
warned of a sharp slowdown in growth
with drastic implications for the world
economy on which china depends
the oil embargo for example has led to
higher prices at gas stations and
supermarkets in europe
there is increasing anxiety about
uncontrolled inflation
the blockage of ukrainian grain
transport is also causing the cost of
bread to rise in europe and a food
crisis in africa
we are not preventing the export of
ukrainian grain
there are many export routes ukraine can
export through the black sea ports it
controls such as odessa
russia
is solely responsible for this food
crisis russia alone
despite the kremlin's campaign of lies
and disinformation
furthermore the russian army has mined
many fields in ukraine and destroyed
farms
who is responsible for the food crisis
let me pass that question straight on to
natalia coupled with the question of
whether we can believe russian claims
that a c corridor for grain exports will
soon be reopened
um so just um yesterday um russian
foreign minister was in turkey and
talked about this about the possibility
of resolving this food situation and
i think for russia this food crisis as
well as the war in ukraine as well as
many other things before is this battle
of narratives while the western
narrative against
russian narrative and in russian
narrative russia is not responsible for
the foot crisis obviously this is the
ukraine is not providing the grain and
russia is
prepared there to
to ensure the safety of this and i think
also what russia is trying to reach out
of the situation is the israel sanctions
they want to trade off
this to the
um let us let west lift some of the
sanctions and then we'll will get the
grain pass and interestingly enough i
think this narrative has actually
resonated with some of the countries
especially in the african continent
because these are the countries that are
actually affected greatly by the food
food problem and
i think past last week
leader of senegal was in moscow and met
with putin about um different issues but
also food security i think right now we
see in some um african countries also
this narrative coming down that you know
maybe it's not
only russia's fault maybe you know the
nato or the way reacted to russia's
aggression is also to blame so
they see it increasingly as as a
narrative competition so to say and
we'll see like which narrative will win
let's get matthew's take on that on
which narrative will win it's the famous
battle for hearts and minds and if we
look at the united nations general
assembly vote uh on the war in ukraine
there were a number of countries that
abstained
and or even voted
against condemning russia
a number of them will be affected by
grain shortages and fuel price rises
what do you think well i think i think
when people are are facing uh a famine
um you know they'll do whatever they
need to in order to to get
to grain um that doesn't mean that they
don't know who's responsible here and i
think it's it's it's it's pretty it's
pretty simple it's really not not that
complicated if you accept that russia
started this war without provocation
then you have to accept that russia is
also responsible for the looming grain
shortage here uh it could resolve the
problem by withdrawing from ukraine and
ending the war and uh everything would
would open up again so i understand that
african leaders are doing everything
they can to to get food for their people
and ensure
grain supplies but uh i don't think that
uh the the president of senegal or
anyone else really believes that uh
vladimir putin isn't responsible for
this crisis and do you think there's a
short-term prospect of grain exports
actually going out or do you think these
promises on this on the part of russia
are uh empty
well i think this is where china could
play an important role as well if they
were to use the leverage they have with
moscow to pressure them and maybe they
already are that could explain these
initiatives by lavrov and others to
try at least publicly we don't know if
they're serious about it but
if they follow through on this to to
open the ports to open uh odessa in
particular to allow grain out of there
um
then i i think you know there is a
chance that you could at least see some
improvement but you have to remember
that much of the grain is still stuck in
silos in the interior of ukraine it's
not in in the ports and that could
really be the the major crisis ahead
felix shortages not only of grain which
you also mentioned would definitely
affect china but also shortages of the
fuel cooking oil are going to have a
major impact in
asia do you think all of that will
influence china to put pressure on
russia what circumstances would it take
for china to say to putin okay time for
this thing to end okay so far there are
no signs that china is really playing an
active role
in a diplomatic role but i think they
are worried especially other countries
who provided oil they also shut down
their markets like indonesia or
or
and india a lot of countries are worried
that there's so much shortage so they
don't export
and
yeah
so i think
yes china might play
more active role but
what they can achieve i have doubts i
think they influence
beijing's influence on putin
the relationship is not so close that
china can make putin to stop the war and
this would be the only result to also
solve the food crisis as you said it's
not about the the ports it's uh it's
that the whole country is
is destroyed by the war and
so only putin can stop that and i'm not
sure if china is able to
make him stop natalia what do you think
how amenable would vladimir putin be
to advice or even pressure from his new
friend xi
well i don't think he will be
commendable to any pressure actually
because i think he's gone very far in
this um
in the war and i think this ukraine
questioned this ukraine problem as he
himself said was it's the very core of
his worldview and the view of russia his
envision for himself so i don't think um
you know china's advisor and pressure
would make him stop right now without
achieving something that he can sell
back home as a victory because um as i
said i think so many red lines have been
crossed um going to this war right now
so now it's you know too late to back up
and say yeah we don't really mean that
you know let us be friends together
again i don't think it's possible
matthew how could
or should the west uh tr seek to drive a
wedge between
china and russia and is there any way
for the u.s to use china to get that
influence on putin
well i think the use of sanctions or the
threat of sanctions against some chinese
sectors chinese companies could be an
effective tool but it's a little bit
tricky because you would sort of risk
retaliation on on the part of the of the
chinese but i think generally speaking
that the us can use its very deep
commercial ties with china to try and
nudge the chinese uh in in in the right
direction here
um i think that europe can do the same
thing certainly uh germany has
maybe better relations with china or
definitely better relations with china
than the united states and also very
deep trading relationships so i think if
if the west in general were to try and
convince china that this war is not in
china's interest it's in nobody's
interest and they should do whatever
they can to uh push russia to
uh end the war and uh and get out of
ukraine
felix i'm hearing companies based here
in germany and elsewhere in europe
saying that they're actually not only
reassessing ties to russia but also ties
to china not only because of the war but
also because of the new ties with
between china and russia as well as the
lockdowns in shanghai the xerokovit
policy and of course the leak of files
on xinjiang
do you think that could have an effect
on how close china is willing to snuggle
with russia i'm not sure about that
because the problem a lot of german
companies already also have
china doesn't rely on them so much
anymore as it used to be
and
you can feel that a volkswagen company
long time very welcome in china not so
welcome anymore because china knows to
build better
e-vehicles
so i'm not sure the danger is that i
think a lot of german companies realize
also with the war in russia too
dependent on one country authoritarian
country is a threat
and this has to change natalia one word
our title asks does china hold the cards
i guess at this point it might be true
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us thanks to you out
there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
you